I want to show you this New York Times
article real quick because the context
is hilarious
make no mistake the investigation of
Donald Trump and the Stormy Daniels
scheme is serious from March 21st oh boy
that was just yesterday and then today
we get a letter proving that it's all
fake news and not real and the New York
Times should be very very embarrassed
for running a story like who wrote this
they deserve credit this is Ryan Goodman
and Andrew Weissman and they write that
yeah yeah idiots well look you know they
deserve to have their names out there
they're like a myriad of crimes possibly
committed by Trump possibly you know
possibly you know what yeah imagine
watching Law and Order sorry and it's
like these are the possible stories that
may have happened we're not sure we're
pretty positive okay I mean it's Loosely
based on a true story that I thought of
then added some details later no but you
know what on second thought the headline
actually is kind of accurate you know
why it is serious the idea that we're
going to go indict former presidents
for things like this
that truthfully
no normal person cares about I like if
if this situation was turned around be
intellectually honest let's pretend it's
Joe Biden okay same situation same
details same everything same letter all
that I don't care there's much more
serious reasons why I would want to go
after Joe Biden his family selling out
to China you know the evidence now that
was released this week by Congressional
uh members who are Republican that
showed the bank statements showing that
members of the Biden family got money
from a Chinese entity that came straight
from the Chinese government and it got
spread across multiple members of the
Biden family which I find more
concerning I find that much more
concerning Ukraine and getting the
prosecutor fired I find that much more
concerning Hunter Biden's laptop full of
300 plus crimes I find that more
concerning I don't find a story like
this if this was going on with Joe Biden
I'd intellectually honestly be able to
say I don't care we look silly doing
this we better not do this I'm going to
come out swinging against it because I'm
not going to make myself look personally
stupid but apparently Democrats don't
have that value they don't have that
chip in their head that goes you know
what I don't want to personally be
embarrassed by this I'm going to speak
out against it they all go along with it
they're willing to be just totally
humiliated as long as it's for a greater
cause in their in their brain and this
is the greatest cause for them they've
been wanting to indict him for years I
don't think they are humiliated though I
don't think they care I think that they
this is activism journalists I mean it's
not journalism but this is state-run
yeah they may be incapable I mean at
some point like when do we admit that
these mainstream you know propaganda
pieces are I mean who are they
effectively working for I mean they're
able to run stuff every single day
completely not factual they don't do
retractions but damage is already done
they sometimes do attractions because
they make money on that too so you can
write you can write a news story Ian
Crossland does backflip and then
everyone's shocked and they click it I
think it's a million views and it's fake
news then the next day you run another
story apologies Ian actually did a front
flip and then you try and milk the views
the ad sales you get from that fake
article you don't give the money back no
no and you know Ian is going to then
post it and be like look I got them to
apologize yep and clicks it's a way of
capitalizing both sides when they do and
they don't always do it but yeah major
news Outlet will write Donald Trump
punches dog and then get a billion views
right then the next day right we
apologize for running the story Donald
Trump did not punch dog and then the
right shares the story and says aha this
proves it they make money off both
amazing huh
but here's the thing about it that's so
dangerous is the side that first saw
Trump punches dogs will always believe
and never be disabused of the notion
that Trump punches dogs they will always
believe that and that's the danger in
the system is that we've we've let it
get to this point where it's just it's
pure poison you know
yep yep I mean what we've been talking
about in terms of wokeness and the the
tribalism in the country is the the
social zombism of the left
you've got a mix of people like we were
mentioning earlier Joe Walsh and uh
kinzinger Cheney uh who else were we
mentioning uh Cohen these people who are
like I know it's bunk but boy I gotta
join the left because that's why I take
it to making money yeah that's their
next ticket that's their next check and
they they the funny thing is the left
argues it's the right that does that and
I'm like okay
name me uh
anyone who was a staunch leftist who was
a die-hard liberal advocating and
yelling Obama who is now coming out and
going Trump Maga 2024. right there there
are some you could probably mention
however if you take a look at the people
they tend to name Dave Rubin Dave Rubin
was never like holding up big Obama
signs he was just a default liberal he
got into politics said hey wait a minute
I didn't know that and now he is where
he is he's like kind of libertarian they
say he was he's grifting you know
because he's been left it's like no no
no you don't understand the average
person I think Breitbart called them
default liberal yep they consume news
from CNN and from The New York Times
they assume it's true and then they're
liberal because of it then when they
start actually digging in and
researching they're like hey wait that
was a lie that doesn't make them
conservative it just means that they
know what's going on in the world you
take a look at these people who are on
the right and on the left and it's like
they had to choose to accept lies that's
the thing we understand when we see a
story like here's a video of Joe Biden
and he's saying if you don't fire the
prosecutor you're not getting a billion
dollars and he says you don't have the
authority call the president ask him he
outright tells in his story that he was
accused of not having the authority to
withhold loan guarantees from the United
States which is correct he does not have
that Authority and then when we tell
people that these these default lib
types they're like that's not sure that
never happened or maybe it's not that
big of a deal I was told that but but
the issue is they don't believe it
happened they don't know it happened
that's the bigger problem so so here you
here you are you'll typically find that
in what I refer to as the freedom
faction where we are conservatives
liberals disaffected liberals
Libertarians it's like
I I saw what CNN said I saw what
Breitbart said I saw what Fox News said
I'm I here's what I think happened when
you look at the left it's like I watched
CNN and that's it so these people don't
know anything
the people on the right know both sides
and then come to a conclusion
exemplified by a graph that I love
showing off liberals only consume
liberal news moderates consume 60
liberal 30 conservative and
conservatives consume 30 liberal 60
conservative which makes sense their
worldviews are shaped by the information
they consume but moderates and
conservatives are willing to listen to
each other to figure out what makes the
most sense liberals don't do that they
only consume left-wing sources tells you
everything so when you see jenk yuger of
The Young Turks tweet that Equity
doesn't exist except in the minds of 12
leftists in the entire right wing and
Bernie Sanders is correct we want
equality of opportunity not outcome that
is the perfect example of what we're
talking about he knows he's lying
because every corporation in school has
launched a diversity equity and
inclusion office or officer how could it
be that these things don't exist
yet Biden has an equity plan yet
politicians talk about Equity talks
about it constantly and then gent year
comes out and says nope never heard of
it because they know they're lying and
they're just saying what they think they
have to say to get clicks if you had
asked him the day before Bernie said
that where he took the position of
equality he would have defended Equity
absolutely no question just one day I
mean an hour before he said it I thought
you could find tweets from him from a
year ago where he's like Equity I bet
I'd take that bet I bet we could I bet
we would find him 100 because they live
and breathe this stuff you know what it
does kind of remind me of though every
once in a while the left does this where
they knowingly lie to your face
um about a failure of theirs and they
pretend it just never happened this
happened with latinx okay yeah all of us
raged like I'm Latino I'm like you're
not calling me latinx you guys are
ridiculous and you know a lot of Latinos
in fact it's a slur I wouldn't go that
far because I feel like really things
like you know the n-word that's a slur
um I didn't get like personally crazy
offended by it but so many people do see
it as a slur did I think it's it's you
know kind of Common Sense hey leave that
one alone people don't like being called
it but they just kept going with it and
they put it on every TV station it was
like instead of Latino stories which by
the way is ludicrous like I'm Latino we
don't need our own section on Amazon
this is Latino stories like just put
movies up there let people pick what
they want I find it personally kind of
imagine there being a white section like
White's only section that's what they do
for Latinos it's like they do it for the
Black History Channel they do it for
black folks as well and I I just think
it's actually really offensive like you
know I think it's kind of ludicrous We
need oh you don't think we can find
movies we like without you putting a
Latino sign but they pretended this
whole thing with latinx that this should
be normalized and then once it failed
and all the Latinos hated it and they
started voting Republican Democrats
pretended it never happened yeah they go
oh no none of us said that none of us
like that we don't you are Latinos
obviously I don't this is a couple crazy
people from college it's like literally
the entire journalism changed the AP
style guide changed to saying latinx all
of your different news outlets said it
you had every single entertainment
section in the country changed from
Latino to latinx and it's only after
your failures that you then deny reality
and tell us no we're gonna guess at you
you're all crazy this never happened
and that's kind of what I think they're
going to do with Equity because it's
it's just so blatantly unfair and people
are starting to understand how
ridiculous it is that's their only
option to go backwards check this out I
just did a Google search NYU
nyu's latinx project receives 1.3
million dollar Grant but then below it
woke latinx term isn't preferred by
Hispanics and Latinos from Norfolk Daily
News that's amazing you know the the
white Libs at NYU really prefer that
term look at this one New York Times
some Republicans want to ban latinx
these Latino Democrats agree surprise
surprise the people who are actually
being insulted are like hey stop saying
that yeah I mean it's it was always so
ludicrous we're talking about like
literally the most gendered language and
culture on the planet it is a very like
I think maybe a lot of Americans don't
fully get this like Latino culture is
very Macho and I mean that even with
like the women love it you know Latino
women they love the Macho culture the
men love it it's like one of those very
gendered sort of deals and there's
nothing wrong with that that's the
culture you know why everybody wants to
find some fault within cultures is just
kind of ludicrous to me yes are there
people who are Latino who don't like
that sure I'm sure there are but you
know what the vast majority do and
that's just the general rule about the
culture and it's okay to recognize that
latinx sounds like Kleenex it does
latinx the kleenex and that's what a lot
of people are like it's kind of just
don't call people words that they didn't
want to be called It's funny because the
left is like call me what I demand to be
called or else also we're going to call
you what we want to call you yes it's
like okay it's a really weird weird
thing it's a weird set of rules they
have they just recycle bad ideas and
then Rebrand them and then retract what
they said that you know whatever doesn't
work they just throw it against the wall
and they're like okay that one worked
they accept it they accepted transphobia
let's see if it works with latinx well
there's no consistent Foundation of
values on the left that's why there is
such Flex you know fluctuations where on
the right we didn't change our position
we value Freedom we don't want to you
know CHOP Children's genitals off we uh
want you know low taxes I mean nothing
changed in the mindset of people's
Center to right but the left is
constantly changing they're the ones
that want you know all age drag shows
they're the ones who want you know
gender mutilation of children they're
the ones who want pornography in school
so there's no moral or value Foundation
that's share that's consistent that's
there is one thing that changed on the
right and it also changed on the left
the left used to be an anti-war party
the right used to be a pro-war party
that is reversing that the normal people
I meet out in rural States and
everything they don't want to get into
another Forever War they don't want to
send their sons to die again for some
you know elitist plot to go take some
whatever natural resource from some
other country they don't want to do it
they're not going to fall forward again
they don't want to spend their money
there and the Democrats love war now I
mean they are literally slobbering for
war money and that's a big change in
Party politics like I think you go 10
years out I don't think you can
effectively be anti-war at all and vote
for Democrats thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time